[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Google Compute Engine
enables you to deploy updates
to virtual machine instances in
managed instance groups using
two different methods.
One, rolling update
incrementally
deploys updates in all
the VMs of the image.
Two, canary deployment
deploys updates
to a subset of VMs in the image.
This enables you to test
the update on some VMs
before the update is
deployed on all the VMs.
In this video, we will
focus on how to perform
rolling update to MIGs.
MIGs support two
types of update modes.
First, automatic or proactive.
In this mode, you can roll
out new configurations
to all or to a subset of the
instances automatically in MIG.
Here are some advantages
of proactive mode.
No manual intervention
is required.
You can automate
rollouts partially
with reactive mode, which
allows you to perform testing
similar to canary update.
Here is a quick tip.
Choose automatic
mode when you want
to deploy a critical update
across instances immediately.
Second, selective
or opportunistic.
You can manually start the
update on selected instances
or when a new
instance are created.
Now, some advantages
of selective mode.
You will have a better
control on the timing
and the sequence of the update.
And here's some tip for you.
Choose selective
mode when you want
to perform a pre-planned update
during a maintenance period,
so that the impacts, such
as performance degradation
or downtime, can
be avoided for you.
Now, let's look at how
to perform a rolling
update in proactive mode.
In your Google Cloud console, go
to Compute Engine and Instance
Groups.
In our project, there are two
instance groups, rolling update
proactive mode, rolling
update opportunistic mode.
Each of these MIGs
have three instances.
Other than that, we
also have two templates
which we use to create
and update the MIGs.
Application version V1, this is
the current version deployed.
Application version V2,
this is the new version
we want to upgrade
the VMs in our MIG.
Select the MIG that
you want to update.
In this example, we will update
rolling update proactive mode
MIG.
Click Update VMs.
Under New template,
click the dropdown list
to select the new
template to update to.
We will select
application version V2.
Under Update Configuration,
expand the selection menu.
Select automatic as the update
type to trigger proactive mode.
With proactive mode, you can
control the disruption level
during rolling update by
selecting the appropriate value
from the dropdown list in
action allowed to update VMs.
With each option, there are
different instance properties
which will be updated.
Select the option that
works for your requirement.
We will select Replace, which
replaces the current instances
with new instance.
Next one is maximum surge.
It indicates the
number of VMs that you
want to create above
the target size
before deleting
the old instances.
Note, the additional
instances will temporarily
run at the same time as
the instances it replaces.
Setting up a higher
value for maximum surge
can improve the
speed of the update.
However, it will incur cost
for the additional instances
created.
Max unavailable.
It indicates the
number of instances
taken offline or unavailable
during the update time.
Note, max unavailable value
can cause downtime on our MIG
if the value is close or equal
to the number of instances
in the MIG.
The default value for max
surge and max unavailable
is 1 for zonal MIG and
3 for regional MIG.
Let's proceed with the default
value of 1 for max surge
and max unavailable.
Next, in advanced configuration,
we have minimum wait time.
This value sets
the length of time
to wait between two
successive instance updates.
All right.
We are all set.
Now click on Update VMs.
We can open the instance
group in another window
to view the instances
being stopped and getting
replaced by the new instances
with the updated application
version.
All right.
Let's now look at how to
apply a selective update.
In our project, select
the MIG, rolling
update opportunistic mode.
Select Update VMs.
Under New Template, select
Application version V2.
Select the option
of selective mode
under update configuration.
Select Done.
Click Update VMs.
Now, click on the
Instance Group.
Select one of the instance,
and proceed for deletion.
There you go.
We can see that a new VM has
spawned up as a part of the MIG
with the new version
of the application.
Note that, because we have
chosen selective mode,
the other two VMs will not
be updated automatically.
Check out the
documentation to learn more
about the proactive
and selective modes
in rolling update.
[MUSIC PLAYING]